2016 is the 20th anniversary of Pokemon  and it may just be the year you catch  them all starting today februari first  Nintendo is giving away a free mythical  Pokemon every month these aren't just  legendaries these are the best of the  best february's free pokemon is mu and  you can grab a code from gamestop that  code is good for Pokemon x/y alpha  sapphire or Omega Ruby and that mew  comes at a super powerful level 100 all  the mythical pokemon do by the end of  2016 you'll be able to grab Celebi  jirachi Darkrai manaphy Shaymin Arceus  Victini keldeo genesect and meloetta too  and those will be available from  nintendo and gamestop the only question  is which six legendaries you'll carry  with you each Pokemon is only available  during its particular month and the  coach will expire only a few months  after that so aspiring Pokemon masters  need to move quick and for anyone else  seeking Pokemon news you're already in  the right place